everybody it's gary vaynerchuck I had a
run into the city to give a keynote
feels like in my car I'm staying outside
my car I'm like thirty minutes late I'm
like I'm not gonna do a video but I'm
committed to doing more Givi cars that's
not an actual URL by the way I made a
mistake of Twitter here's my little
thing it's a quick tip in but I wanted
to share it there's something going on
with businesses out there today and
especially the way they handle social
media and and really the way they handle
all their marketing and I want to give
you the analogy because analogies really
stick and I think they matter now let me
first say that this is a very profound
thought for me inside I really really
want to articulate I gotta get it out
more but I wanted to share it with you
since it's the top of my head right now
I believe that most businesses today
when they think about marketing or
acting like a lot of women friend of
mine now let me first say the dudes are
way worse I'm all-in on women I hate
dudes women are the best but I notice
that a lot of brides spend more time on
planning their wedding more energy and
effort in planning their wedding than
they do putting into their marriage and
I truly believe that that is the analogy
that I see from a lot of business I just
don't think that people are thinking
about the lifetime value enough social
media if you're looking for a quick
score to justify its value compared to
an email service or Google Ads or any
other banner conversion things sucks it
is a lifetime value toward us in the air
play it's the difference between putting
your energy into planning your wedding
putting your energy into your marriage